I think if there's a thing that I could
go back and tell myself you got to do
things because you believe in them and
you want to do that I was bullied some
for sure especially my first said I want
to be an actor I mean kids they didn't
they thought was weird and you know a
more traditional neighborhood where I'm
from in Kentucky if you live in a state
of being worried or afraid for things
that's not the motivation the positivity
that I want to have in my life or around
me I want to drive forward with what I
want to be doing next and like you know
just in the moment my passions and my
you know energy my happiness just
because like a relationship comes to an
end it doesn't mean it's a failure it's
a learning process for every heartbreak
that you have you're also redefining and
further defining what you're looking for
in a person it was actually really hard
for me to make friends that I really
couldn't talk about my emotions with and
talk about my true deep feelings with
and only in the last a couple years have
I really made those friendships it's
worth to wait to find good friends in
your life like worth going through all
the not good friendships or the the non
meaningful friendships because once you
get to that place where you find people
that you really connect with is so much
better if you look at the people that
influence the world in art and politics
everything they are different they were
raised different whether they were smart
or where they were artistic or they're a
little bit weird like I was I was kind
of a lot of those things and and so I
stood out as being different people out
there who find themselves feeling
different or they know they're different
I think they should embrace that a
hundred percent because that the
difference is what leads to greatness
[Music]